This episode of what if discussed is brought to you by manscaped.
Obviously people are in different situations.
Some people have a really terrible time. They're living in Palm,
Greek at living where there are a lot of people around it, close quarters.
And for them it's a very scary time. People have lost their jobs.
People are dealing with all kinds of very difficult circumstances,
maybe have lost, loved ones or friends,
even for those people who haven't suffered the worst of COVID.
It's a challenge.
So Peter, I've asked you this before,
but sort of a different time. So I'll ask you again,
how are you doing? You mean in terms of a pandemic and my,
my mental acuity while it's kind of a loaded question in these times,
I guess all things considered I'm doing all right. At least outwardly facing.
Um, but you know, the pandemic's been tougher on some people more than others.
Yeah. I mean, it's, it's eight to nine months into what's. Uh, you know,
it's almost a cliche now to say unprecedented times what it is. Um,
but now as you know, many people,
depending on where you live in the world are also facing sort of second waves,
you know, uh,
new lockdowns sort of starting to re you know,
reacclimate themselves to what potentially could be a, a tough winter, right.
Uh, with lockdowns isolation.
But it depends who you are because you have heightened anxiety about your
health, about your family's health, about your, about your financial situation.
There's a lot going on. It's tough. Yeah.
I'm getting a little bit anxious knowing that, uh, you know,
we're heading into about,
I don't know that we're necessarily heading into a lockdown in this city,
but we're certainly heading into six months of winter where
I'm going to be inside. Not speaking with a lot of people face to face,
and we already have heard over the last X amount of years, I don't know, five,
10 years is kind of when I remember the word starting or the acronym,
sad, seasonal affective disorders. That is, yeah. That's what it stands for.
So that's something we've started to understand more so again,
without getting too in-depth about it. I mean, essentially,
it's kind of what happens when the days get shorter,
but also you don't get outside more. Oh, the days are getting shorter. My gosh.
Yes. And then the sun, although interestingly breaking news,
hopefully something we can report, uh, here in the coming weeks,
there is the contemplation of not putting the clocks backwards or
forwards canceling daylight savings,
which I have been a proponent of for the last 25 years. Well, if not now,
when yeah, exactly. This is so yes, this is the time to do it.
I could almost see like people revolting if they don't do it, but it's a,
it's a tool in the toolbox that governments should seriously consider. Uh,
but seasonal effective disorder is something that, again,
depending on who you are and you know, some people suffer more than others,
but now as you enter a specific time where you're like, okay, wait a sec,
seasonal affective disorder, plus I'm going to be in lockdown a lot.
This recipe for a lot of people is pretty scary.
Sunlight loss of vitamin D. And now a lot of people are saying, you know, what,
if we're in lockdown throughout the winter, how challenging would that be? Well,
it's an understanding.
One more question. And it's one I've had,
I've been in conversations where people are literally asking that like, man, I,
this is, this is really freaking me out.
So obviously when we're faced with a situation like that,
we'd like to obviously be able to use science and also be able to
provide hopefully some helpful guidance to people when possible.
And in this particular case, I think we probably, I mean,
we literally are bringing on today, the person who not only coined the term,
a seasonal affective disorder, uh, sad,
but also literally wrote the book on the subject. Um,
Dr. Norman E Rosenthal.
Dr. Norman E Rosenthal is a world renowned researcher and
psychiatrist who led the team who first described seasonal affective disorder
or sad. He's also a sought after public speaker and a bestselling author.
Who's known for his innovative research and inspirational writings.
He's currently the clinical professor of psychiatry at Georgetown university
school of medicine and is listed as one of the best doctors in America.
Dr. Rosenthal has written over 200 scholarly articles and authored or
coauthored eight popular books, including winter blues,
the New York times bestseller transcendence,
and the Los Angeles times bestseller the gift of adversity.
Dr. Rosenthal, thank you for joining us today on what if.
Oh, it's a pleasure to be here. So we wanted to have you on, well, we want to.
No, I have you on for a couple of reasons. Uh, you know,
one is that many people,
these days are wary of what looks like at least in the West, uh,
a long-term lockdown possibly a couple of months possibly
into the spring.
So you combine that with the winter months and you have people
concerned about how that could affect people, could have a mental health crisis.
So you are the person who literally coined the term seasonal affective disorder
or sad you and your team.
And you're also somebody who writes a lot about how to deal with it and how to
inspire the ability of many people to feel better during
these times. So, first of all, let's start with sad. What is sad?
Well,
it is a condition where the days are getting shorter and darker
and some people are very susceptible behaviorally and emotionally to
those changes may begin to feel a low energy level.
They have a hard time waking up in the morning.
Everything seems to lose that special luster that it had in the summertime.
They lose enthusiasm, and sometimes it gets even worse than that.
They over eat that oversleep and they can lose their ability to
function. Optimally, it works,
suffers their personal relationships suffer and they can end up feeling very
down and depressed and anxious.
So there's a spectrum ranging from the mild to the severe.
I've given you a more severe picture, but that is the full blown,
seasonal affective disorder or sad.
How does it differ from just regular depression?
Is it just that it's in different seasons or is there something else to it?
Sunlight, et cetera. Yeah.
Since it's clue is that it occurs seasonally as you, our,
we are now entering the autumn.
So if somebody's been very well through the summer and they suddenly begin to
feel not so well, all the things I've described,
then they may think that they have seasonal affective disorder. And then I said,
think back, how did you feel last Thanksgiving?
How did you feel at Christmas time?
If you weren't the life and soul of the party,
if you just resented all those Christmas tours and didn't enjoy
all the things that we are supposed to celebrate at that time of the year,
maybe you have seasonal affective disorder and not just regular depression.
Hmm.
Uh, you've been treating people for over three decades now,
30 years and been on the cutting edge of research in the field of mental health,
um, suffice to say you are tapped in to the collective psyche.
What are your patients telling you these days about these unprecedented
times?
Well, even before the seasonal affective disorder kicked in,
and now I'm hearing from my patients that they're beginning to feel it certainly
here in the mid Atlantic region up North,
they've probably felt it for a while and down South.
They probably aren't feeling it yet. But, um,
what I hear and have heard is that there are tremendous
emotional stresses involved in the COVID story.
And obviously people are in different situations.
Some people have a really terrible time.
They living in congregate living,
where there are a lot of people around a close quarters.
And for them it's a very scary time. People have lost their jobs.
People are dealing with all kinds of very difficult
circumstances may be, have lost, loved ones or friends. Uh,
but even for those people who haven't suffered the worst of COVID, uh,
it's a challenge, uh,
because we've lost a lot of the things that we came to love and depend upon
eating out, traveling, hacking our children,
our grandchildren dating, if we're single, um,
you know, the idea of romance, all of these things as a style,
as our style has been crimped in regard to all of these things.
And, um, you know,
a lot of people are sort of throwing caution to the wind and having
these connections in groups closely connected with each other.
But then a lot of them are coming down sick and we've heard the plaintiff, uh,
messages on TV. I wish I'd listened. It really is worse than you think.
And then, you know, it's, it's a very variable illness.
Some people hardly get ill at all, and that can fool you.
And some people get very, very ill.
So it's an unexpected thing that we're dealing with.
We don't know what we're dealing with.
And so there's fear and anxiety and deprivation.
That's what we're dealing with on top of the seasonal affective disorder.
A lot of the work that you are doing these days is,
is obviously focused around helping people deal with the times we
find ourselves in. We talked about sad already.
We talked about the potential of a real mental health challenges
going into the winter months.
What are some of the things or anything specific that you're
telling people tips wise to help them cope with, uh,
the challenges that they're facing right now?
Well, I think that as, uh, the revered, uh,
psychiatrist, Victor Frankl said,
you can take anything away from the person accused or her
choice to view a situation. And in his or her own way,
how you view a situation makes all the difference to how you deal with it.
So I think that if you look at what you have your
circumstances and say, okay, this is reality. I have to accept it.
It's no point saying, well, I wish there weren't an epidemic.
I wish there were not a pandemic. You know, that doesn't help anybody.
It's much better to say, look, this is the situation we're dealing with.
How can we do the best job of it? And then once you faced up to that,
then there are several things that I have found to be really helpful.
The first is to maintain, structuring your day.
You're going to bed and waking up, do it on time,
make your bed in the morning. Lecture place look lived in and decent,
not like a college dorm. Um,
and then exercise is fantastic because it's part of the body's way
of tuning itself up, eat properly. And, um,
I meditate.
I find that meditation is an amazing tool to help me get through.
And then I use lights, lights in the morning and dark in the evening,
or two fives, your circadian rhythms,
those daily clock clock processes that go on
unconsciously in our bodies. Every cell has a little cluck in it,
and there's a master cell in the brain that orchestrates all these cells and
they make our sleeping awaking as efficient as possible.
So work with your circadian rhythms and lightened,
dark powerful stimuli, that curiosity, Caden rhythms.
So once you're doing all those things,
you keeping your structure normal that's step number one.
Um, in your book, the gift of adversity, it's a, it's subtitled,
the unexpected benefits of life's difficulties, setbacks, and imperfections.
How would you say this applies to the times we find ourselves in now?
Well, it's a great question. What is it that we cannot do now? We can't go out.
We can't eat out. We can socialize. We're pretty much stuck.
So in my own case, for example,
I've wanted to write a book for a long,
long time on the healing powers of poetry.
It's just love of mine all my life, and I never really got round to it.
But now with all the time that I have in terms of not doing
the things I just mentioned,
it's the first time I've actually knuckled down and I'm nearly done with that
book. So, uh, that is an example, but everybody's going to be different.
Um, I talked recently to a woman who was
supposed to have her child get to teaching online and
the teaching fell through for the day and she thought, well,
why don't we bake cupcakes? So they baked cupcakes.
And so little mini example,
but these are just two tiny examples of an infinite variety
of things that we can do. It. We're created my clients.
Some of them are starting to paint. Some of them are learning to sing.
All of these things, incidentally can be facilitated online.
One of them is making jewelry.
The opportunities for a creative and
inventive person are endless.
So I would say don't just see it as an unmitigated
disaster.
Think about it as an opportunity to do things that you may always have wanted to
do, but never actually got around to.
Going to be a lot of fallout, legacy, collateral damage.
However you want to term it of this particular period that we're in and
especially in your field,
in the area of psychiatry and helping people deal with whether it's
PTSD, whatever that is,
this feels like there'll be even new areas of study post
COVID and perhaps pre other things down the line.
What do you anticipate some of those new fields of study might be?
Well,
I think all kinds of new opportunities are going to come out of this pandemic
or example.
We know that a lot of people are realizing that they can work very well from
home.
So I know a colleague who runs a large company and
70% of their people say they don't want to go back to work after the
COVID is over. And I think a lot of people are feeling that way.
And then of course,
a lot of corporations are licking their lips at the idea of not having to
retain so much real estate with people working at home.
And then of course,
that then creates a challenge for people who are holding that really state.
So the whole society has this ripple effect going through it based on
these new discoveries. Um, for example,
my own practice is now gone totally virtual online.
I hope that someday sooner, rather than later,
I will be able to see clients in my own office.
But I think that all kinds of possibilities are opening up that weren't there
before.
I agree. I think it's a necessity is the mother of invention.
I think though the world is going to change possibly a lot of the ways for the
better, because we have to figure out how to navigate this time. Dr. Rosenthal,
you're also sought after as a motivational speaker to inspire people around the
world. What are some inspiring words you might be able to leave us with today?
Well, I would say stay connected, reach out to friends,
reach out to family. How are you doing, how you feeling, um,
be connected. We, we, uh,
know that loneliness is a very toxic state.
One thing I'm finding for example,
is people with addictions of all kind can now attend their
12 step meetings or other meetings virtually online.
So it makes it very easy,
but you don't have to have an addiction in order to access a group,
find a group of people who resonate with you and with whom
you can actually make connections. I think that's such an important part. We,
humans are not meant to be alone. We're meant to walk.
Primates are meant to grow and evolve in groups in
societies, do something creative,
do something innovative, do something fun, fun.
Don't squeeze all the fun out of your life.
That's what I told a client of mine recently,
who's working so hard day and night. I said,
you're squeezing all the fun out of your life.
And that leaves us with a feeling of deprivation that we need to replace with
something.
So just have fun into an unusual gift to
somebody that you thinking about or that you care about. Um,
I think we have to invent ourselves, invent our lifestyles,
invent our relationships in new ways. So spend a little time being creative.
And of course it's become a buzzword now gratitude,
uh, but it truly is a wonderful state of being,
uh, just checking in with yourself. Some people write a formal
gratitude checklist every day.
I just keep reminding myself that I'm alive.
And part of this amazing pageant that is the 21st century
with all its Horace and all its nastiness and none the less
fascinating place to be in a fascinating time. So
accepts that carnival to the extent that you can. Hmm.
So you, don't your,
your prescription isn't Doritos and Netflix necessarily occasionally perhaps,
um, uh, great words and, and inspiring.
And I think important for people to hear and hear again.
And I think the idea of reinventing yourself taking the opportunity,
but in the end, it's really about first step is, is, is seeing it, uh,
as, as something that can be constructive versus destructive. Uh,
we really appreciate, can you stick around, uh,
we have a few more questions that, uh, we'd like to get to on the audio version,
but first, um, where can people find your work?
This place is my website,
Norman rosenthal.com and the website will access all my social
media, the Facebook, Twitter, LinkedIn,
Instagram, et cetera.
And these are all places you can find me and read about
things that I love and things that I know about.
I've got a lot of blogs up there and, uh,
so please check me out.
And yes, you can purchase the books there as well. Um, uh,
we'll be back with Dr. Rosenthal on the other side, please sit tight, uh,
Dr. Rosenthal and Peter, and I will sort of take care of some business and,
uh, and, and review the first part of the show, uh, for people who want to,
who want to get the audio version, uh, click on the link below, right?
That's right. We'll uh, if you're already listening to the audio version,
you're going to look around, but, uh.
For video, I don't know if I have one, one or two minutes more,
but I failed to mention transcendental meditation,
which is the kind of meditation that's been quite transformative in my life.
And I recommend very, very highly I've written two books on that subject,
transcendence and Superman. And of course I have a book called winter blues.
That's the standard for seasonal effective disorder and the gift of adversity.
So these are some things that may provide people with some comfort, inspiration,
and new ideas at this time.
Some tools for people looking to deal with difficult times, but not necessarily,
depending on your attitude, negative times.
It's ultimately about your perspective, Dr. Rosenthal sit tight.
We'll be back after this. Thanks. Thank you. So, Peter,
I believe it's Einstein who once said that the definition of insanity
is.
Equals MC squared. That.
I think that's something else that's relative.
Insanity is, uh,
performing a repetitive task over and over and expecting a different.
Correct. So we sat here, I dunno, a couple of weeks ago, I believe.
And, uh, the people at home were treated to you figuring out that,
you know what, maybe not shaving for three months with my Methuselah,
like clay off beard was not the way to go. And you.
Of course, we're saved by,
I was saved by the lawnmower 3.0 for manscaped.
I shaved everything. Right. I mean, it wasn't that long.
I was just sitting here.
I do keep it quite trim like this and just shaved the big pile of yuck right
there. I'm sorry to discuss.
Better. Thank you. You felt better.
Uh, yeah, I did feel better and I do feel better.
And I'm going to use this lawnmower 3.0 from manscape to probably keep it trim
and maybe even shave the whole thing off.
Well, as we go into another period of isolation and lockdown,
and we did talk to Dr. Rosenthal today,
there's plenty of things around structure and sort of keeping your life normal
in a way that's going to help you deal with the challenges.
One of those things is definitely not, uh, not showering,
not shaving getting into the sweats and not getting out of bed that literally
not only will you look better with the old lawnmower 3.0 and a clean shave
you'll feel better. You'll feel better and manslaughter.
As changed the grooming game with their perfect package. 3.0 essentials kit.
This complete package comes with the new and improved lawnmower 3.0 a water
resistant cordless body trimmer, their advanced skin,
safe technology and cutting edge ceramic blade makes your trimming Nick free.
And the kit includes an anti chafing deodorant and moisturizer to help you
feel and smell your best subscribers to the perfect package. 3.0 kid,
get a new replacement blade delivered to their door every three months.
And for a limited time, you get not one but two free gifts,
the shed travel bag and the patented high-performance
anti-gay thing. Manscaped boxer briefs.
You can get 20% off plus free shipping right now@manscaped.com.
When you use the promo code. What if 20 that's?
What if 20 that's? What if that's,
what if 20 all one word well done? Well said. Thank you.
Um, and it is interesting. It's an easy segue, because again,
we're talking about, you know, most of the, at least the Western world is,
is going into two things, one probably a second extended lockdown, potentially,
however that works.
And however long that might be too combined with the wind the fall months,
and then the winter months, which can be challenging.
As we talked about with Dr. Rosenthal already,
for people that deal with seasonal effective disorder. Now they're staring down.
Six. I mean, we're depending on what hemisphere you live in.
And we live in a colder one where we're looking at six,
seven more months of cold, not to, not to depress anybody. No.
But I mean, it is, but again, back to what Dr. Rosenthal talked about,
it's avoidance, isn't gonna work either, right? So, um,
attitude is everything. And I know when, when you're,
when you're suffering and I've dealt with mental health issues, you know,
I don't know a lot of people these days who haven't,
it can sometimes almost bother you to hear somebody say, ah,
just turn the frown upside down. Right. But in this particular case,
the good news is it's also accompanied by not necessarily
regulatory health tips, because a lot of these you're like, wow,
they all make sense. But in this particular case,
they don't just make sense for your physical health.
They make sense for your mental health.
Yeah. And I think you bring up a good point. I think we should not, uh,
nobody should be stigmatized by mental health.
I think we're getting to this point in the world now that, uh,
mental health is health and people should be able to talk about it and
admit that they're a, that they're having a hard time.
So I don't think anybody should be going through these times and be afraid to
mention what's going on or be ashamed, especially in sure. Especially now.
Was real serious stuff. Yeah. And he,
and that sort of dovetails into something else he talked about. Um,
have you heard of blue zones? Uh, I don't know.
There are these areas of study. I recently read about that.
No, I do know like Japan is a blue zone. Yeah, of course.
It's in Japan, Italy where these people live to like 110,
like I'm exaggerating here. But so of course,
when they started to see this over decades, they were like,
we got to study these people, what's in the water over there. Like,
why are they whatever they seem to be. So of course they study these people.
I think there's pockets in Italy, there's pockets in Japan, to your point.
There's other places, even some, some rural parts of China,
some parts of South Africa. But again,
the one thing they had in common was that people lived longer and happier,
healthier lot. So of course was diet important. Yes.
Was it the number one? No. Was exercise important? Yes.
Was it the number one? No.
The number one determinant of these long happy healthy lives, Peter was what.
Uh, well, I'm going to say mental health, but there's probably a,
you can probably narrow it.
From connection and social interaction, social interaction. Okay.
As he talked about, like when people feel dis people don't feel,
they have people care about them who need them, who, uh,
you know, it, it translates into, you know,
what do I have to live for and what they have found again. And again,
this is the science proves that social interaction is very important to our,
to our overall health and long and happy, healthy laws.
We're of course not in a period where we're going to be able to do that the way
we used to do it in person going to concerts, going to games,
going to bars, going to restaurants, friends, places.
But as Dr. Rosenthal talked about, it's not the same,
but making sure that you make it a part of each day to connect with people,
even if it's through zoom can be a big part.
Yeah. And also to, uh, you know, get creative,
don't stop using your brain. Like use this time. Don't just sit there,
pull the covers over your head,
like get out of bed and do something like learn poetry.
Write a book as, as, as Dr. Rosenthal talked about. And again, I know there's,
some people will say, yeah, easy for you. Uh, you know,
I have these certain whatever everybody's situation is different.
So you don't want to be, you know,
sort of putting out like a one size fits all solutions.
But the one thing that we can control are some of these things, exercise,
how you eat, connecting with people.
The other thing that I prescribed to people schedule laughing in your day,
meaning.
Like real laughing or just like that fake laughing where people just go,
ha ha people do do that. Yeah.
Talk about, I've been in yoga classes where people do that.
I was filled with rage. Now that's my own personal problems.
Probably a little too much information.
It doesn't necessarily work for everybody, but for me,
whatever I'm going to be doing, whether it's working,
whether it's doing these other things as part of your regimen,
I also schedule like watch whatever it is, something that, you know,
is your go-to that you're going to laugh for half an hour, some stupid show,
dumb videos, whatever it is,
but make sure you get that sort of going because it's actually literally,
as they say, laughter is the best medicine.
It is. And if you want to hear more of our conversation with Dr. Rosenthal,
and you're watching the video podcast on YouTube,
maybe you're switching back and forth from a bunch of funny cat videos to get
your laughing. Um, well,
what you can do is you can click on the link below and go to the extended audio
version. Now, if you're already listening to the audio podcast, uh,
we'll stick around.
We're going to be back with more about health risks of isolation.
And we'll talk about your emotional intelligence with Dr. Rosen, salt Rosenthal.
So, um, don't touch that dial. Uh,
if that is all the time you have for us today. Well,
thanks for watching and we hope you learned something.
And we really do hope and we know it's tough. So obviously reach out to the,
what if discuss community on Facebook? Also,
there's a bunch of other people there. I mean, whoever,
as he talks about whoever,
whatever you got to find in terms of some group to sort of support you,
you know, now's the time.
Yup. Perfect. Thank you very much for watching. What if discussed?
[Inaudible].